okay all right I think we're live
welcome to fake guru guys you all know
why we're here we have the man of the
hour
Caleb Maddox I want to take a second
Caleb if you don't mind to explain sort
of how we got here and then we can go
from there
just real quick I didn't realize until
we're Hardy live d grab some headphones
real quick can you get somebody grab
Mike don't
okay yeah no I'm just learning about the
feedback maybe learn to fake guru guys
you all know why we're here we have
thoughts Matt phones Emperor will make
happen
yo first I want to say bro I really
appreciate you taking time to do this
like doing it live I love there should
be no editing no cutting out of both for
it I'm not editing anything I'm not ever
cordless you could literally do whatever
you want to this thing and so it be but
I love this just alive but we're gonna
have a conversation and you know
honestly a lot of people that I've
talked to you there's a lot of people
that love you by the way I've got so
many messages and people like yo this
guy did a video about you and they now
hate me which I don't really mind that's
why I'm doing this I can clear that up
but I think it's unbelievable
audience you build another one so there
are a lot I would love you but not a lot
of people in the space that I know that
are not fans of you obviously cuz like
you said to you before we even click to
record because you cost them a lot of
money but I want to say I personally
have nothing against you I really think
the fact that you do what you do is very
admirably because I understand there are
a lot of people in this face that are
fake gurus that don't know what they're
talking about in the courses they have
don't actually impact people and I can
tell you before I just ask you what's
your life mission is that that's my
mission is to help other people get to
the life mission and you cherish is like
I want to I want to basically exposed to
industry so I can make sure people are
safe no no no no no I'm Kayla but let me
interrupt all right and let me take this
I said it's something I want to do on
the side I mean I don't want to do this
forever as I said coffee break right no
I just want to say what I have to say
cuz I saw an industry that is
unbelievably predatory
towards people who don't know any better
and don't know the sales tactics that
are being used
and I appreciate I appreciate the kind
words by the way but we don't agree on
everything and in a lot of ways I think
you do the same things that I accused a
lot of people of that's why we're here
let me give some context of the audience
so the reason we're all here is I made a
video about you where I said I've made
two videos I want to cover the sales
call so I made a video when you were 14
years old or 15 you did like you made
this video called the $10,000 sales day
in it you have this sales call that's
recorded where you allegedly closed a
$10,000 deal and anyone who wants to go
watch that video could watch it I have a
lot of issues and we'll get into that
but the second thing we might talked
about was your whitey a method course
okay so this is something that launched
recently and in it you make some wild
claims like this is the kind of claims
that I'm talking about that I hate in
the industry and I'd like you to explain
where you fit on them and I want people
to hear you out because you call it the
greatest opportunity of our era you say
I can say that with full ethics you know
all this stuff I can't but it turns out
that the greatest opportunity is
basically like repurposed copypasta
reddit videos made by five or people
because I saw that you said the video
and once again I said you do have a lot
of people that definitely follow you
because I got a lot of messages of like
you're doing scam beer edit videos and
they told me exactly what they thought
that's not at all when I teach in fact
you look closely at the maths class not
a single time I even talk about
repurposing content when I talk about is
OPC and what OPC is is using other
people's channels to learn from its
modeling this the thing that has changed
my life I believe there's power in
patterns so if you look at the YT maths
class not a single place and you can go
watch it I'll give you free access
you're gonna do a follow-up video after
actually have an access to it I'm happy
to do it not a single place so I ever
mentioned repurposing content the only
evidence you had about repurposing
content was that Devon white party with
I'm writing a hundred thousand dollar
check to to create the whitey amass
class with me you said that he has a
ready camp that is used one of the
channels he has he owns dozens of
channels and just one of them is read it
with that one voiceover that's kind of
like
automated completely if you will look at
a single person side of the Lyceum ask
us I believe there's one person has
already outside of them okay the first
thing I would love to clarify it's not a
single time but I ever talked about
refurbs not what I talked about is using
OPC and this actually something like
Michael fussier because I want to impact
people this is something I recommend for
anyone that's anything you want anything
in life you need to use other people
that already got in that thing that's
why I said there's power in patents for
me growing up I wanted to impact
millions of people so I looked up to
people like Tony Robbins and I studied
what they were doing how they did what
they didn't I did that I wanted to have
billions of dollars not so I could just
be rich but so I can use that capital to
change education system so I studied
Warren Buffett I studied throw game I
studied GUI there's so I could learn
from that and for me that's been one of
the alternative funds why 18 is all I'm
a multi-millionaire done things I've
done it because I've studied the
patterns of great people you want to be
a great basketball player
study Kobe Bryant okay let me live it
let me I wanted to let you finish in the
last I'm still learning to do these
interviews and stuff like that and I try
to strike a balance between I don't want
to interrupt you but at the same time
sometimes things go off on a tangent so
the reason Devin having reddit channels
is relevant is because you hold him up
as an example of the yta being a
business opportunity let's be clear the
business opportunity is not learning to
copy other people who are successful
that's the most obvious basic self-help
thing that you learned like from
self-help 101 is learn from other people
it's like what humans do pattern
recognition you're real you're real
opportunity is YouTube automation and
saying it's such a good opportunity and
that specifically is it is a niche that
you're like showing people how to do so
that's why it's relevant that Devin and
it's not one channel I showed one of his
channels because I didn't want to show
all his channels but I I have a list of
them if you'd like to hear some of them
can I read off some of these for you you
get so so here's the thing when he's
bragging about how much money he's
making he's making this video about how
he's making all this money the examples
that he chooses to use are all reddit
channels so reddit Shack was shown
reddit Watchers was shown reddit and
chill was shown sir reddit
was shown bamboozled was shown dr.
reddit was shown right like these are
it's not one channel it's like dozens of
channels because repurposing reddit
content is like a wave that you could
have ridden if you got on it early on
the problem is is it's being demonetised
because this kind of lazy content
YouTube doesn't want it on their
platform and about YouTube automation is
this you can't get a super high quality
following super high quality product
without having a personality behind it
that's actually giving in effort so when
people just say oh yeah it's so easy you
can just hire people out hire them from
Bangladesh Thailand India whatever and
you don't have anybody actually leading
the creative side it's not a recipe for
success like you're saying it isn't like
you're representing that it is and
that's why I think it's this big sham
because you're saying hey the yti method
ytyt a method look at this guy making a
ton of money but the way he made a ton
of money is back when you could make
tons of money on reddit videos and as I
showed you the what he's talking about
his make he's making tons of money our
reddit channel so would you like to
respond first first things first you are
correct when you first started out the
first thing she did was using right now
just some of the first videos did he's
completely gone away from that in fact a
lot of these channels aren't gonna be
completely shifting right up why because
YouTube is cracking down on the huge
great content to me that's not any type
of defamation of his character because
in a day if you can have a video that's
way easier traits in other videos that's
going to - so ready buddy o's are
extremely some of the freakiest you
literally only be someone to do a
voiceover you can have a machine do it
Dru's pull a bunch of red stuff it's
easy great now all of that is channels
he's no longer creating reddit specific
channels in fact inside the white a mask
class I specifically tell people with
Devon not to start right a channel
because you don't want content that is
too easy to create so with that Devon
guess you made a lot of money went
reddit I'll agree with that a lot of
chance for that now Devon has literally
over I can name I like in my head I have
five channels that he had outside of
reddit that are still making the money
that he launched a channel three months
ago and in the first two videos not in
the reddit niche the first two videos
that he launched where one
and he was four million views and the
next we got a million views he did it
completely automated it was in the
reddit each and he blew up that fast so
for me and I understand you say you
can't make money unless you have some
sort of personality from the camera I
understand where you're coming from but
what about bright side WatchMojo what
about all these new channels that do
exactly that okay okay a few a few
things here a few have a few things here
okay nobody would argue that there are a
few channels that exist out there that
happen but what you just admit it I want
you to understand this what you just
admitted is look you used all this proof
on your webinar that you can make so
much money the proof in the webinar was
not used from purely ready channels in
fact the one I show was one of those
newer channels a lot of it was a lot of
it was because they're just they were
just no they were just Instagram where
he was they were taking they were taken
straight from his Instagram story okay I
also there was dozens that warrant well
what's the proof no no the proof is this
you just admitted where he made most of
his money was read it back in the day
and he's having a shift away from that
friend money you never explain to the
audience don't you think it's
disingenuous to never explain to the
audience that the way this guy made the
majority of his money that you know of
the majority of his money is through a
system that no longer works and that the
same thing may happen to future Nisha's
because ultimately this low effort
content it gets phased out and like
that's why he's having to move away from
reddit is because you try to do
something super super low effort try to
use reuse third party content and it's
not copyrighted content but it is
third-party content and when you do that
people just you don't build up a
following you don't it's just this super
temporary short term like try to white
right away while you can and maybe
Devon's good good at it but it said it
the opportunity of our era that's
ridiculous dude you got to agree that's
ridiculous it's that ridiculous and
here's why first things first Devon has
multiple channels outside of the
renovation hey brother I'll bet you do I
won't cut you off you notice I'm not
cutting off waved it in I did the exact
same thing all right man it's nots gonna
go Devon ash channels in me she's
outside of red
then have five times a subscriber thing
we do on your YouTube channel
with your personality that people seem
to love not only that debbie has dozens
of friends who do the exact same things
have and follow the exact same method
and it's not easy to create content in
fact we teach people the right way to go
hire a voiceover actor the right way to
go hire a strip life the right way to do
all these things where they produce
content that people enjoy watching and
to where they produce content that isn't
just easy to create it's automated
but there's a merchant automation of
these when the CEO of a company like
Amazon as an otaku look at Jeff Bezos
Jeff Bezos will having higher company
startup underneath them thank you not
put a single piece of F into now was it
you see what simple no but was it
automated for him yes you see the keys
to get people onto your team that put in
the lot of work that most people do on
their YouTube channels and you automate
them completely and that's exactly what
we teach and if you went through the
whys you master class and not just the
train which by the way I will fully
stand by it's the greatest opportunity
of our era look at during one of the
number one recession in our life and you
know one recession well become fun well
Ray Dalio the multi-billion dollar
investor believes heavy a Great
Depression YouTube cute in the past year
even throughout all this YouTube and
past year they have double if you look
at how much they made revenue last year
and who look at how much they made this
year they have paid out more money to
craters this year than they made in all
of revenue last year and for me is it
what I believe is the greatest thing
ever did you know for me I believe I
want to impact millions people I believe
the gracing for me is going to be the
fact that I'm gonna change education
system which I want to dive deeper into
what I believe it's the great
opportunity of our era because it
doesn't matter who you are doesn't
matter what you look like
it doesn't matter how your voice sounds
doesn't matter where you're from
there's people and after using it
there's people in America using this and
all of those people are taking event in
my opinion it definitely the grace
opportunity of our Erin it's not just
one person there are duds and the people
that I do exactly Devon impact there are
hundreds and hundreds of people doing
exactly what that does and if you don't
believe it you can go on YouTube and if
you scroll from five minutes what I see
what you do if you are youtuber you put
out
enjoy I assume you at least don't do you
to a little bit if you go through
YouTube you will find hundreds of
completely automated channels that are
taking advantage of the greatest
opportunity of our era okay me saying
greatest opportunity of our era very
forcefully doesn't mean anything and let
me try to run you through some the real
greatest opportunities of our era the
real greatest opportunity of our era was
getting in the ground floor on Facebook
was getting in on the ground floor of
Twitter on any of these tech companies
trying to get into a saturated YouTube
market is the greatest opportunity of
our yeah it's such textbooks like sales
manipulation and I wanted to ask you I
want to ask you at the beginning of
saturate you to market first of all
YouTube gets one point each really news
every so year to be that's not saturated
and secondly its doubled this year it is
doubled within a year a company that's
already one of the biggest companies
below that one of the big comes with
Google for eons it is double for you to
call that saturated to me is
unbelievable and I understand to get
into the ground for face for 100% but
there's only a small handful of people
that could have gotten in at the ground
pork but hundreds of thousands people
doesn't matter who you are what your
education background is where you live
or what language you speak you're just I
mean I mean I I hate to say this you're
just wrong I mean yes yes yes the more
YouTube viewers are on than ever but way
more creators are on the platform than
ever I have a lot a lot a lot I have a
lot of friends in YouTube and all the
time what we what we hear consistently
is when you see people who got in at
like a good time you see them their
channels huge because they got in at the
right time people start trying to start
channels right now you're never gonna
become pewdiepie cuz you started at the
wrong time a lot of these channels
they're big because they started early
on it does that mean you shouldn't go
join you - no I would never encourage
that I joined YouTube late I mean it's
fine you can make an income but is it
the greatest opportunity of our era hell
no and by the way the the automation
market
is getting saturate I mean I looked at
like the reddit nish butt niche niche by
the way Devin's still post to the reddit
niche he's still relying on that just so
everybody's clear he's not if you
haven't asked it that's producing you
money you're not going to completely
strap okay what I'm saying though is
listen the reddit niche if you look at
that it is just pumped Pumped pumped
full of content because people realize
oh this is a super easy niche to get
into and it was at a certain time so now
just waves of text to speak speech
automation are going in it was a much
better time to get an early on now it's
worse just because you can say oh it's
double the view somehow it's a great
opportunity it's just not and that's
this kind of sales speak drives me
insane because every single gurus out
there I hope you know every single gurus
out there saying this is the greatest
opportunity no this is the greatest
opportunity
no this is the greatest opportunity and
honestly none of them are that great
because people try them out and guess
what for ninety ninety to ninety nine
percent those people it doesn't work let
me ask you a question do you think lying
while selling is ever justified okay
okay not to do it but during the gold
rush when one vein of gold was saturated
they didn't say the gold rush was oh
they wouldn't found me yeah but you know
who made most of the money during the
gold rush the people saying what it
could opportunity when it was doubling
every single year no no the people
selling the shovel the people selling
hey you guys want to know how to make
all this money look at the opportunity
of our era go - go - go let me sell you
at nine hundred ninety seven dollars
shovel go sell hey guys it's the
greatest opportunity of our era look do
you actually believe that the people who
made the most money back on the gold I
think they made the most money
consistently absolutely I mean
absolutely yeah yeah yeah
look do you think the people making the
most amount of money on YouTube are not
is not YouTube itself like you think
it's not Google the platform the
platform for these things is always
gonna make more money of course of
course that's just and that's the
economies of scale like Amazon it
doesn't really it too
platform it's a platform for people to
sell through and they're saying like
yeah this huge ecommerce gold rush the
real gold rush is Jeb being Jeff Bezos
right now I agree with that doesn't mean
that someone shouldn't take advantage of
it
no and that's not what I'm saying so
what I did for the opportunity chef
bae's doesn't get away from being a
great opportunity no no no impact those
people make it a hundred million dollars
here hold on and Jeff Bezos although
although he made is worth over a hundred
billion dollars he's made $200 plus
three amps on he's also provided eight
hundred billion dollars worth of other
well so you guys use the well appears
but that doesn't mean someone should
take advantage that opportunity okay yes
and I know I want to be real careful
here what I'm not saying is that YouTube
automation doesn't have a place for
certain people who want to pump out
content I've never said that you you
said it's the greatest opportunity of
our era which is patently ridiculous
no no but you just can't say that I mean
that's like you saying this one video is
worth more than college anyone can just
say something but if it's not true if
there's no no evidence you can pull out
that that's true then how can we believe
it you've one guy who's making some
money good amount of money I'll grant
you but it's not crazy amount of money
it's not like like eight figures kind of
money it may be seven figures I don't
know but it's not eight figures I mean
it's like a decent amount of money this
is not like some incredible market it's
just not I mean eight billion creators
get paid out over here sorry eight
billion dollars okay okay how many
creators are there so you're saying you
know one person but but how many they
are okay Caleb many creators are there
and how many of those creators are using
the yta method as you say right everyone
know why doing creators getting paid for
example this is one thing I would agree
a lot of people do create themselves I'm
gonna retract that and I'm gonna say for
the first time on this I agree I was
wrong just by saying that solar attract
that okay what I mean is the youtubers
that when the most on YouTube number one
friend I have my friend who makes 60
million dollars a year plus he has his
channels fully automated yes he's the
one in front of the camera but he has
his channels automate he's not doing the
editing he's not doing that
and that's we teach inside a YJ even if
you want to be informed the camera
that's where we have celebrity nation is
bonus you need to want to get from the
camera you can do that but it's the
automation part and when it was fab a
part about why today is the signs of
virality showing how to actually go
viral on YouTube that is the most
valuable part even outside of the
automation part things and there's one
thing I wanted to say I understand you
at the same time people invest $1,000
but there's one thing that you're
forgetting to say I'm not scamming a
single person out of a thousand dollars
you know I know why because it went five
minutes within five minutes someone not
liking what they thought they can get a
full refund on that money with no
questions asked
we will fully refund it so if someone
gets in maybe that's a thousand dollars
and they don't like they see you know
what I think if adopted they get their
thousand dollars back and they lost them
but if someone gets in the invest
thousands and they go out and they
follow what's inside the master bus and
they go get you 100,000 and I'm trying
to look up your oh no no no no no I'm
trying to look up your refund policy
real quick 30 do refund okay so here's
the thing here's the thing you can't
really test these things that fast I
mean like like I first of all great for
you for giving a 30 day refund policy
like I'm glad that people do that but
when you're saying that this is the
greatest opportunity ever and then the
language towards people who are buying
this thing is like oh if you didn't
succeed well you just must not have put
in the work you just must have in there
I wouldn't recruited someone from
ritz-carlton and what they did I brought
them on just the WoW our members so if
someone said they didn't get results we
don't go oh you're not doing enough we
go what questions can we answer for you
what can we ship to you what can we get
in your hands and we do everything with
our team I mean I mean you see you see
you say that you don't say that but
there's like there's a video of you
floating around where you say that poor
people are poor because they quote pass
a pass over opportunities repeatedly so
you say oh I don't I don't tell people
hold on
you say you don't tell people that it's
their fault when they don't succeed but
then you call poor people passing over
opportunities repeated poor people are
you just help I will today but I will
say no I say to everyone if someone is
watching
I believe they took advantage the
opportunity in our job to get the
results but I believe every single
person doesn't get results and they
don't have success I do believe it is a
hundred percent their responsibility and
you know why because if someone like
Oakland she was abused hulagur you look
at her backs like she was poor she was
abused she was an african-american woman
in America that she grew to the point
where she's a multi-billion dollar
business woman and one of the number one
host of all time it is yeah I believe
that's one of the number one problems
with the current education is with
everything you they they make people
believe that somehow they can't win the
only reason I've done what I've done in
my life and I was fully certain that I
would do that thing and I obsess on
getting there i sat down with Arnold
Schwarzenegger look in the eye do you
Multi multi million dollar movie star
greatest movie star ball highest-paid
actor but uh one of the greatest
bodybuilders of all time and the
Governor of California and he would say
the exact same thing so I understand
what you're coming from but I guess
everyone can't understand greatness I
have always believed small minded people
will never understand big fingers okay
all right well I would just like to tell
you that that's maybe the worst take on
poverty or environmental factors that
I've ever heard Caleb listen to me right
now listen to me right now you don't
think if you don't know what my name is
Suren Stephen but I appreciate your my
dad when I was younger I was he Street
with people little little kids who had
no pillow to sleep on they would sleep
on the floor
they'd be crying I'd be holding them in
my hands you know what be thinking every
school time I did that I need to create
something but in suffering for people
like this so when you sit there and say
that I don't care about people in
poverty clearly you did not see the way
I was raised and why I knew every single
action I take I didn't say that people
think that I'm motivated to make money
when they don't understand it I would
wake up in the middle and I with tears
streaming down my face because of kids
that are suicidal and the thought that
I'm not there to them yet
I'm fully motivated not by making money
but by collecting the resource I need to
be able to impact those people okay
happy for me the number one
why do everything I do why I want YJ why
I do everything is because I understand
that I have a moral obligation on this
earth and I'm not gonna let some guy on
YouTube that's named coffee Zilla
stop me from getting messages from kids
that say I'm the Reedman and commit
suicide unit if you I mean when I was 14
years old
telling me not to think sales call us or
whatever it was but donors say is that
exact same 14 year old kid was
responsible for thousands of kids live
to be better for kids that didn't commit
suicide and I understand you're trying
to point out they through is that
respect that but when you have someone
message saying that they didn't commit
suicide because of you that's the moment
I'll put you in my own category are you
saying that never happened
I get fan mail all the time what are you
talking about and by the way by the way
let me talk about where someone cry
major you did your monologue and I
understand that you're super impactful
and yada yada yada do you understand
what you just said though the irony of
what you just said you said my dad took
me on all these trips when I was young
okay that is already like this thing
that shapes who you are and gives you an
perspective and advantage on life over
all these are so for you to say to say
say to me that oh yeah if you're poor
and you stay poor well it must have been
because you passed over opportunities
because Oprah because you know Oprah
that's so ridiculous that's it's just
it's just creating a trying to attribute
a simple solution to a multi-faceted
problem and no offense I think it's
indicative of how young you are that you
think that's such a complicated problem
as poverty can be fixed I'm 26 so I
would say that I I have I objectively
have more life experience than you and I
also don't know the answers right I mean
yeah like I'd like just objective I go
back no I'm not trying to have a dick
measuring contest with you right now
what I'm trying to do is explain to you
that you you thought you had the answer
on poverty
three years ago I
have the answer on poverty you're
riveted strips I said this is not apply
to people in third world countries no no
I danced it from Americans so we go okay
but but what I'm saying is that you
thought when you were 16 you had poverty
figured out that's what I'm just saying
that sure it is ridiculous man I don't
think I know I fully understand how
poverty works but I'm not gonna pretend
like I do and I don't think you should
be either you think no no you understand
why people are poor and the reason
they're poor is because they pass over
opportunities repeatedly and you just
understand and that's exactly why
because they wake up every single day
not realize now for sure they have yeah
I start to get all motivational on to
the opportunities called life and I
totally understand where you're coming
from and I agree with you you said that
I'm only successful because of my dad I
already had an advantage by 110-degree
that's why I create something called
apex for kids to instill in a hundred
thousand plus kid 100 thousand plus
students exactly what my dad instilled
in me so you're right when you say I'm
only successful because I have my dad
but that is why I have such a strong
core obligation to do what my dad did
for me let me clarify I don't think
you're just successful because of your
dad I think you're successful because
you're operating in one of the sleaziest
industries imaginable and you're taking
advantage of a lot of people no taking
money from people under the got like way
too much money for people under the
guise of giving them basic self-help
stuff that they could find in a book
that's ten bucks yeah of course the why
you think I'm taking money from people
do you think they take money unethically
no no no no because there's a clear
except because you say that you that
automating reddit videos is the greatest
opportunity of our era
dollars for a concept that's so simple
that it can be explained in ten minutes
a thousand dollars make people hundred
thousand dollars and sure you can give
me a free login I've watched the person
who like goes through it by hand you're
like a food critic who's criticizing a
burger in every
no I'm like the guy who found your guru
who found your guru and found all the
channels that he's bragging about and
they're already at videos
I'm not know I do is give advice yes I
do why today but every single day in my
life I'm working on crane something
changed education system what you don't
know what's behind the scene most people
they do is be a guru online behind the
scenes I'm creating an AI that literally
is going to learn kids here's my mission
I believe the current education system
is too one-size-fits-all that's a
problem of the current education system
it takes people through this assembly
line it teaches them the exact same
thing over and over and over and over
again for kids that are vastly different
from mine for completely the opposite so
I'm creating AI with my business partner
Ryan that work kids don't just learn we
learn them where the AI figures out the
way the kids learn so that we can still
the right things in their mind so for me
I'm not encouraged if you think that
were Michael would not have viral videos
my goal is not to create some internet
marketing product
my goal is impact all eight billion
people on earth by creating a
revolutionary educational AI with your
partner yes okay
okay I mean I don't know what to say
it's shocking it's shocking well I do
want to I don't want to stay on this
topic forever not not I want to get away
from whitey a method I feel like we've
talked about that a lot I feel like we
all have a lot to talk about from there
I mean we talked about you guys want to
join whitey method it's learn
y-t-dot-com for /home I don't do that
don't do it guys unless you want to sell
Reddit videos by 26 year old have a
fantastic you to care with I respect by
the way you are applying a lot of the
principles inside a yj5 respect for that
you guys want to learn the principle
that's made coffee Zilla blow up on
YouTube learn y-t-dot-com port slash
live but I understand how you don't
think I have life experience but all
would put up against you
amount of people impacted the amount of
money made I got the other day I
understand where people are coming from
but like don't throw the whole life
experience being on me bro
I understand you're eight years older
than me we'll see where I'm at at 26
years old no no no no
no no it's it's not about it's not just
about like oh I'm trying to save it
because I'm older I know better than you
I'm saying that you don't you don't even
know what you don't know I don't think
because I know that I don't know the
answer to poverty and I don't expect
that there's a single answer to what
name when you roll back that's why I
want to know anything okay right and
they can watch the video where you which
you're defending which is saying that if
you're poor it's because you pass over
opportunities repeatedly right no no
also just poor people though not poor
mentally like you just said poor people
I believe that if you're in America and
you report that's why I do everything
that I do but I believe that if you're
born part it's not your fault and you
guide poor it is it's called the
American dream I live in a Sunday School
room at seven years old my dad I had
seven dollars to our name my car got
repossessed we have to fight right every
single day to get food and I defy cried
to school I've seen kids who grew up in
shelters I've talked to people or worth
a hundred million dollars that were once
homeless this is America if you're born
poor it's not your fault
I'm here for you if you died for it is
I'm just I'm just a little sad I mean
let me be clear I'm not saying the only
reason I'm not saying that the only
reason for being poor is environmental
I'm saying it's a multi-faceted problem
that's way over your head and it's way
over my head and it's absurd that you
try to pretend like you know okay so let
me ask you let me ask you that sales
call speaking of things that you did
when you were a little bit younger and I
wanted you to give you the opportunity
by the way to kind of renounce that poor
statement I thought you would because
you are older and hopefully wiser okay
well there there it is but I also wanted
to ask you about your ten thousand
dollar sales call right or that you
would admit that that's fake
right here's story I'm gonna just did
yesterday please please yes yes or no
you know what the answer okay
what's the answer okay I did a sales
fall at 40 years old I close at $10,000
deal I ran the other room I said dad I
flew the ten thousand dollar deal
I told him exactly what I said work for
it my god like you should record that no
I know I wish they would he got on video
I would output it to YouTube I'm an
announcement coffee so once again I said
I'm gonna say a few times on this
interview that I was wrong I refilm
exactly word for word what I said on
that sales call to a team it was a close
eye he was a lot when I was 40 years old
and I read from that video and uploaded
it to YouTube so congratulations okay
all right I I mean people can decide
whether they want to take your word on
but if people don't think I'm good at
psychology watch this interview okay
what do you mean good it's like what do
you mean go to psychology okay uh all
right so I want to ask a few questions
from the audience I asked the audience
to give me some questions about you did
we get any super chats I would love to
know if we got any super chats so far
hold on let me see let's see if we got
some super chats I can't tell okay I'll
check this out if you guys gave a super
chat thing I'm sorry I couldn't get to
it you dip out 145 what time is it oh
you got ten minutes yes
oh dude okay oh shoot okay guys we got
10 minutes left
oK we've covered the yta method you you
still think it's the greatest
opportunity ever just might literally
every other opportunity being better
let's see here one Goldie asks why don't
you do the whitey a method yourself and
earn from it rather than selling a
course about it I do
okay what what channel is it
I like I said you might buy it automated
chill but I will tell you my youtube
channel I just art uploading three days
ago I uploaded three brand new videos so
it's you two back on board last
geomatics okay alright but oh I don't
know what to say here but and I don't
mean this as a dig at all you don't have
a lot of followers so if you're applying
like the virality that you're talking
about it's not working I that's not
that's not a bad thing because I don't
think life is about okay what do you
think maybe talk about whities it's calm
down so you're all do we'll do a follow
up in every with 6 months
you'll see you're my subscriber counts
out there that was fine secondly I
haven't discipline that did you - I
applied it to Facebook and that's how I
had it for the other reason 40 million
plus people without to be sealed I'm on
it and dozens of viral videos so the
viral method actually does work and
that's why I'd ever use it to 10x your
subscriber count for sure
okay let me ask you this I'm not surely
an expert in YouTube yes I've been
around people with 20 billion Plus
subscribers yes I've had been at videos
on Facebook and it reached 20 million
people yes I have leverage social media
to reach millions people and I just
reach them but impact not do which is my
goal on today that's also why dished out
one hundred thousand dollars of my own
money you have Devin who has had dozens
of channels give hundred thousand
subscribers why him also teach it with
me because I understand that I want
someone action that goes specifically to
apply that and I learned a lot
throughout the process and that's why
it's six months you'll see what my
subscriber counts at okay so I want to
ask you this do you feel like people are
getting cheated with with these
get-rich-quick schemes a lot of okay why
really what makes you different from
other gurus really uh and nobody else
does or most people aren't getting
results but results have programs
special if they give them results I
wouldn't call him a scam and nothing I
have a problem but they don't offer a
refund awesome
that's why we give me 30 every fun
you can leave without theoretically
spending any money
so we're stationary oh did you spit
nothing best case scenario I'm going to
be providing for someone's family
because of what I taught them in fact we
had people three weeks till I got
layoffs for their jobs they make you
sitting at fort in your strength got
laid off their job and now under the YT
channel they employed five people
underneath them and I already having
videos ever do need tens of thousands
but it leaves that - makes us there it's
resolved where is your refund policy I
can't find your refund policy so if you
watch my entire YT train your dinger
skip yeah I like a lot a lot of these
gurus they'll say they have a 30 day
refund policy and they won't actually
get people their money back I hope you
do know that's a thing that happens
right kind of the same time and also
people who I've talked to kids young
people in general that if their little
lives to be changed because like I
wouldn't be standing here if it wasn't
for the grooves the fake gurus I looked
up to Tony Robbins
Jackie Enfield Gary Vaynerchuk Grant
Cardone ty Lopez those people shaped Who
I am
well yeah I think everyone come round on
this face a lot of scams but to me
that's why I don't know myself a part of
this space my GU visionary difference
okay
okay your visionary got it and I'll
become very where in 10 20 years ago I
may maybe it will you know we'll have to
see I think if you keep selling courses
you'll make a lot of money because
there's a lot of money to be made in
selling courses and ripping people off
I've had I've had a lot of people come
on the show and talk about you say that
YouTube automation making random videos
is the greatest opportunity of our era
well it's just just fun is just buddy
that in his own thing where he's talking
about like how he made his money he
shows like seven different channels and
they're all reddit channels and we're
supposed to just take for granted that
oh yeah there's oh no no he's got so
many other channels that are the real
thing he doesn't rely on reddit these
are the
that's just ridiculous I mean you can't
you can't deny that that's a pretty
compelling evidence right
like all seven of the vid all seven of
the channels that were accidentally
shown that he was bragging about we're
already videos
you can't deny what started channels
with basically no capital upfront and
it's gone actually more viral even the
right of channels did and I cut that
beginning so if someone fish this entire
interview make sure to watch over you we
covered a lot of things yeah we have
once again yg masterclass says that sort
of read channel those chrony I'm working
back then of course you want to take
advantage over to you that's what we
tell people to have entire y team
networks channel and pyro YT apart nice
one channel what it does
let me ask you do you track how many
people succeed with your program how
many people succeed with your program
well first things first
we just launched 30 days ago so our
excuse tracking testimonials a lot of
people on the stages of automating their
tales completely hiring people but we've
had a lot of people that have already
gotten a good patch of viral videos but
I don't know the exact number of people
that have gone viral quote-unquote but
we've had the majority of people who
have joined yta already have their
channels in place in fact are on we have
a place that we post up our job post on
online jobs pH so many people have
applied YT that just bought the court
it's not just bought the master class
but have applied what is inside the YT
of master class for the skilled online
jobs pH reach out to us instead that
we're maxing out the server now the
funny part is I don't share about online
job to you until 70 percent into the
master class which means our the far
majority the people that are inside the
why to you master class are getting past
70 percent so we have one of the highest
completion rates of any master class or
any course in the entire industry
mmm-hmm so let me ask you this so you
talked about you said that it's
unethical to lie while selling right and
you believe that why is it that you say
your webinar is live when it's not no no
I know but you know as well as every
guru knows that the webinar
most of the webinars not live the one
you put up I don't like
why are you saying that this video is
something to watch on the replay I'll
change the description and by the way
every component of the video will be
it'll be very clear that it's not live
gurus including yourself make it appear
as if their videos live because they
want to deliberately deceive yeah
because I know the industry Caleb but
don't pretend like the exact oh so some
of you watching this in a weekend
they're gonna know this we're recording
this is not live at the current moment
there's no one reporter your was live
during the moment recording I don't see
how either really create a webinar you
say hey we have an upcoming event we
have an upcoming live webinar event then
in the thing you say hey leave your
comments in the chat box and I'll I'll
see if I can answer a bubble blah and
then on top of that whatever ballad you
build the webinar out such that it looks
like you don't pretend like you're not
trying to deliberately make people think
it's live you are when it's not and you
said that you don't think that lying
while selling is ethical so how do you
square those two yeah we don't say it
was a live recording and now it's it's
effortless so people watch that live
recording iPhone 3 hours my life's
anytime creating unbelievable master
class sorry our webinar that's already
impacted millions of people and alright
hundred thousands do you not sign
language you're saying though I'm not
gonna recap that and also we do actually
answer the comments lot so the actual
recording itself isn't for the comments
are do you understand how you're trying
to I get what you're doing and if you
said you're like you're you try to use
psychology that's what you're doing
you're trying to justify this but you
came in this conversation and I assumed
you're gonna come to this conversation
being reflective and honest and I don't
think it's very honest to pretend like
what you're doing is not deceptive can
you agree it's active I want to come to
an agreement here
you don't think live webinars putting
all this time and energy into making a
webinar look live appear live all the
languages came look what we used a
replay
and on the page you can say it says free
training so I don't understand how we
repurposed a video that was live and
then we answered the comments live
I don't understand how that's an issue
but I understand it's the only basis you
can now come to it in our discussion
free signup next class starts today that
doesn't imply that it's going to be a
live webinar and then it says check your
availability it's no listen listen I I
feel like you're being deliberately
obtuse here like when it says that
there's you select a date and then these
are the dates that you can choose from
for the webinar to appear where they
want to watch 50 minutes will allow them
to do it it's the way we get some Bost
people so watch our webinar and if
people are being impacted by what we're
putting out there why wouldn't we want
to be people as possible to see it now I
understand that
oh okay so this is again this is a
little bit different from what you said
you said at first that lying was never
justified then you said well if it makes
people pay attention why wouldn't we do
it it's not a lie I'm saying reasonably
a lot like so they find the time they
want to watch it isn't a lie and in fact
the fact that the fact out of all these
fake gurus you expose your only premise
at the end of our conversation is that
we recorded a live webinar and it was as
a replay the same way we're doing right
now on this street this exact moment
that to me I don't understand what
you're coming from i I don't I think
you're being deliberately ignorant to
where I'm coming from because you don't
like the result and how it makes you
look because I think and I think you
could watch the chat right now you could
watch what people say about this you are
being deliberately ignorant of the fact
that it's obvious what I'm doing while
it's live I say it's live then I take
away the live from the description and
also there's a timestamp that's very
clear that it is not a live thing it's
very obvious for my youtube video that
it's not a live thing we're really
crafting you were deliberately you are
deliberately crafting something
you gotta hop off is it past 1:45 but
I'll be it let me clear this up once
again should I filmed it live what you
guys recording we're gonna get beat and
as many people as possible to watch it
so when you impact them not a single
part of that is a lie I remain in
integrity but I understand where you're
coming from I really appreciate your
time today and if anyone does want to
join why Diego to learn y-t-dot-com for
its last time you wanna let me know what
you thought about this mess don't do it
I don't like people pitching on my show
I don't like people using my platform to
pitch on my show I look guys joining
this movement and being a part of the
mission to change the education system
and thank you so much for everyone who
supports me thank you so much brother
yeah but going and genuinely he's not at
the place that you're coming from
because I understand although to most
people it appears is he from you it's
the perspective that you share well the
people and people that I expose see it
as hate the people who were saved money
seen as a very good thing the people
that you expose for those people have
also changed millions of people live
there was really different lives that
they have changed see you and hey that's
all I'm saying it's not the gurus they
hate you if the people who look at the
people that you're exposing
quote-unquote and their life will never
be the same because of them their life
is better and you're exposing is a thing
that's favorite I really be drought hop
off thank you so much your time
appreciate one the chat yeah okay all
right Caleb all right guys well what did
y'all think any final comments I'm
reading chat here let's see here I'm not
a guru coffees Allah protects his
undefeated record that'll get to bed
Caleb sweet gee booth - sweet dream
Caleb jobs sorry guys if I didn't get to
any of your super chats let me try I see
Lorrie Barrabas says
celeb 19 exposed let's see do we have
anything else here that's all I see for
right now guys I'll get off I'll say
that this I don't know I think this went
pretty much how I kind of expected it to
go I was a bit surprised that there
wasn't more of a he didn't kind of
concede some of those points I thought
he would but anyway I guess you'll be
left to make up your own mind which is
how I like to leave it anyways
let me know what you think of the
comments below and I will see you guys
later